[Música]
sabe lo que es esto es mi primer gran
sueño cumplido quiero empezar con una
pregunta muy simple alguna aquí ha
enseñado una vez con ser astronauta o ir
al espacio puede levantar las manos la
mayoría de vosotros bueno soy julián
fernández y yo también tenía estos
sueños he soñado con poder explorar el
universo y dar un pasito más para el
progreso de la sociedad como dije unir
amstrong del 69 y son bromas son más de
los sueños pero que dejamos atrás con el
tiempo sabiendo que sólo están al acceso
de las grandes multinacionales empresas
y la élite de la sociedad voy a contar
una historia desde niño mi afición
siempre ha sido el destornillador
desmontar todo se encuentra todo lo que
se encuentra en mi camino cuestionar el
cómo y el porqué de lo que nos rodea de
acuerdo con tres años mi primera
curiosidad fue hacer agujeros en el muro
con el estropeado
como podéis imaginar que a mi madre no
le hizo muchas gracias pero la segunda
vez que lo hice creo que ella debía
entender por qué hacía agujeros en el
muro de hecho me compré un bote de agua
trust para tapar el muro la siguiente de
metros y era mi cerebro intentando
entender que había detrás de ese muro
era mi curiosidad por entender el mundo
que me rodeaba y seguramente se han roto
decenas de móviles televisiones radios
ordenadores por miradas y curiosidad de
querer entender cómo funcionaban y la
curiosidad en la manera más fácil de
entender de aprender en la tribu inglés
a casi todo el progreso y el
conocimiento de nuestra humanidad y esta
curiosidad me me ha llevado a investigar
ya crear varias cosas a lo largo del
mismo relativamente corta vida hasta
ahora y entonces bueno
yo he hecho algunos proyectos ahora de
mi vida aquí se ve en una máquina de
compostaje que desarrollé para parar
en un proyecto hace unos años un kart
nada que ver con el espacio esto es solo
porque en ese momento me gustaba la
mecánica tiene una curiosidad por solar
por entender cómo funcionan dos motores
de combustión un avión solar
teledirigido autosostenible para dar eso
bueno a la medios de transporte para por
ejemplo medicinas monitorización de
grandes tareas el lunes que desarrolle
en general sólo proyectos que
alimentaban mi curiosidad algo que yo
tenía que satisfacer y es impresionante
como a mí me han preguntado varias veces
hoy julián por qué haces esto si no es
un trabajo si es una tarea del colegio
porque te vas a poner a investigar
porque te vas a poner a hacer cosas que
te gustan que es un poco raro
sin embargo entonces estos proyectos que
yo desarrollé obviamente disfrutaba en
lo castilla y tuve gente que me dio una
total libertad de pensamiento y que me
ayudó a mis tardes de leer foros de
investigar de hacer agujeros en los
muros
bueno volviendo a nuestro gran sueño del
espacio
estos son los aceites de investigación
terrestre de la nasa son satélites para
estudiar el campo gravitatorio es un
poco la idea que tenemos cuando pensamos
en el espacio cosas que valen millones
de euros que son desarrollados por miles
de ingenieros que tardan años en
desarrollarse y desde luego que no es
algo que haría un ciudadano normal estos
satélites los utilizamos en nuestro día
a día para cosas desde navegar con el
google maps a optimizar la cosecha de la
agricultura analizando la humedad o el
ph del suelo o analizar el cambio
climático son unos ojos sobre la tierra
que monitorizan un poco desde una vista
global entonces cuando supongamos que
nosotros queremos lanzar un satélite al
espacio somos un estudiante de 16 años
queremos lanzar al espacio sin
experiencia e información el primer paso
como llegamos al espacio una patadita en
órbita no es tan fácil
y ahora espacio requiere una complicada
combinación de mucho combustible
explosivo y cohetes y no sólo hay el
problema de llegar al espacio que es muy
caro porque llegar al espacio cuesta más
o menos un kilo de objeto espacial en
órbita baja cuesta unos 50 mil euros
su uso peso en oro también tenemos que
obtener licencias permisos para poder
llegar al espacio
tenemos que construir algo para ir al
espacio en este caso un satélite algo
muy complejo desde luego que no está
dentro de la capacidad que uno creería
de una persona sólo le preguntas a
alguien en la calle oye creo que puedan
son suttle internaliza desde que decir
eso deja ser a la nasa dejas el abajo
historia europea o aún un ejército y
entonces yo me encuentro en esta
situación de querer lanzar un satélite
al espacio por mi cuenta es información
sin experiencia yo soy ingeniero
aeroespacial y estoy una posición de
ponerme a estudiar una ingeniería ha
despertado con 16 años
y nosotros frente a estos problemas
cuando tenemos estas grandes ideas estos
grandes proyectos somos simplemente
darnos la vuelta y llegar a la
conclusión de que algo no es posible
y no entra dentro de nuestras
posibilidades aunque algo sea
científicamente factible siempre existe
en ese momento en el cual decimos esto
esto lo puedo hacer esto no entra dentro
de nuestras posibilidades y esto en
nuestras posibilidades y quiero
dividirlo en dos conceptos principales
que son el bueno el esfuerzo y el tiempo
que le queremos dedicar agua por ejemplo
podemos lanzar un satélite lo podemos ir
a comprar una barra de pan ambas cosas
no son muy comparables pero involucran
un tiempo y un esfuerzo determinado
realmente es a nosotros de poner desde
delimitar donde queremos
o hasta donde queremos dedicarle tiempo
y esfuerzo a esa actividad específica ir
a comprar el pan porque tardan 5 minutos
y un paseíto ladrón satélite puede
tardar 5 años y puede involucrar miles
de horas pero ambas cosas son
científicamente posibles y se pueden
realizar con un tiempo y un esfuerzo
específico y detrás de este tiempo y
este esfuerzo es posible específico es
necesario una fuerza nosotros no hacemos
las cosas mal y porque así y no hay
mayor fuerza que la pasión la pasión es
algo que nos lleva a disfrutar de lo que
hacemos se ha lanzado un satélite o
trabajando en nuestro día a día
así mercado si tenemos pasión por lo que
hacemos vamos a disfrutar de ello y nos
va a dar la fuerza y la motivación para
seguir adelante
bueno ahora voy hablar un poco acerca
del tema del internet y cómo entra en
juego en este proyecto está bien tenemos
el tiempo tenemos el esfuerzo que
tenemos la pasión sin embargo como he
dicho que no soy ingeniero yo no tengo
el conocimiento para poder lanzar un
satélite al espacio
y aquí entra una herramienta bastante
importante que igual le damos por bueno
por escondido no no lo vemos muy muy
claramente ese internet es una librería
completamente abierta para todo el mundo
acerca de todo el conocimiento que ya
sabemos hemos descubierto es decir si lo
puedes imaginar seguro que una de las
7,5 miles de millones de personas del
mundo lo han documentado a mí me
preguntan a menudo julián te consideras
una persona inteligente yo digo no sólo
se buscar las cosas bien en google
tenemos mucha información en internet
hoy en día ya no hay excusa para no
aprender él literalmente podemos buscar
alguna pregunta en internet
instantáneamente podemos satisfacer
nuestra curiosidad
y podemos aprender en este momento yo no
soy ingeniero y no tuve profesores que
me formaron sin embargo en internet
lakers inglés trabajos de fin de máster
play artículos toda esta información de
manera autodidacta para poder llegar al
objetivo final y aparte internet darnos
acceso a una librería global de
conocimiento también nos conecta entre
todos nosotros desde cosas como las 6
marc sentidos la conectividad de una
comunidad entera a comunicarse con una
persona al otro lado del planeta en un
foro online
voy a poner este ejemplo de este
satélite utilizarlo redit es un foro
online con más de 330 millones de
personas equivalente a la población de
eeuu donde la gente publica temas
aleatorios desde nenes de gatitos a
ponerse a hablar de física cuántica en
un foro y yo abrí un hilo aquí hace año
y medio diciendo si julián fernández
quiero lanzar un satélite al espacio de
nuestra idea que de hacerlo de esta
manera y no sé si hubieron varias
personas formadas o formamos un equipo
y yandel república checa y richard de
inglaterra donde bueno decidimos
ponernos este objetivo de lanzar un
satélite al espacio sin conocernos no
nos habíamos visto nunca de hecho no
hicimos una videollamada hasta miles
dentro del proyecto simplemente porque
teníamos pasión y nos gustaba lo que
estábamos y lo que estábamos haciendo
y bueno esto que veis aquí el satélite
cosas a uno en el satélite que hemos
creado en estos en este año y medio como
parte la asociación fosa systems que
creamos en ese hilo de riddick y es un
satélite de telecomunicaciones hubo
cinco centímetros lados como podéis ver
que no es muy común en la industria como
habéis visto antes un satélite puede ser
mucho más grande suele ser desarrollado
por grandes empresas y no tiene este
tamaño la mentalidad nuestra fue muy
simple si lo caro de llegar al espacio
es la masa y el volumen pues vamos a
reducir la masa de volumen y vamos a
utilizar la tecnología y entra bastante
bien
con nuestro nuestra era actual de
miniaturización en nuestro teléfono
tenemos acelerómetros baterías
ordenadores tenemos casi todo lo
necesario para un satélite para
realmente poder dar un servicio sea de
monitorización o sea de
telecomunicaciones en el caso del cosas
a uno a la tierra y a lo largo el
proceso de construir este satélite sólo
quiero que veáis por ejemplo estos
cables de aquí
conectan los paneles solares es
necesario calificar de hasta este
detalle que los cables no pasen en vacío
que no contaminen otras superficies
tenemos que elegir estándares estrictos
de la nasa de la agencia espacial
europea por ejemplo las placas solares
tienen que estar calificadas y tienen
que estar probadas para no degradarse
con la corrosión del oxígeno atómico son
muchas cosas complicadas que hemos
tenido que ir buscando respuestas sea en
internet con nuestra librería que
tenemos accesible o buscándolo en la
vida contactando con miles de
universidades de todo el mundo para
poder llegar a estas respuestas cosas
como la radiación que encontramos en
órbita no no es tan fácil desarrollar un
satélite
y esto que veis aquí soy yo en un traje
muy bonito en la universidad rey juan
carlos eso es el laboratorio de
caracterización de dispositivos
orgánicos donde tuvimos que fabricar el
satélite en un entorno limpio y ahora
voy a hablar un tema que es el creer en
nuestros propios proyectos creer en lo
que estamos haciendo yo tuve acceso a
este laboratorio pude contactar con
universidades y tuve oportunidades
porque con las personas que hablaban
transmitía y compartía mi pasión por lo
que hacia él transmitía el proyecto
entero una persona era capaz de ver qué
es lo que estaba haciendo era capaz de
ver los diseños que estábamos haciendo
con una mentalidad opensource ver la
pasión el trabajo que está involucrado y
entender qué es lo que queríamos hacer y
ahí encontramos personas que nos dieron
acceso a sus instalaciones y que
vencieron las oportunidades desde el
primer momento que decimos las al
satélite al espacio creíamos que era
posible
sabíamos que era posible tres miles o
cinco años no sabíamos cuánto iba a
tardar no sabíamos cómo se iba a hacer
pero sabíamos que se podía hacer
pero
bueno 6 de diciembre de 2019 me
despierto a las 7 de la mañana para ir a
ver el lanzamiento del cohete electrón
desde nueva zelanda esto ya lo podéis
considerar un éxito el saber que tu
satélite está ya realidad tu sueño va a
ir al espacio y se va a cumplir el
proyecto en el cual creíste toda tu vida
pero para mí esto no es el éxito para mí
el éxito de este proyecto ocurrió antes
ocurrió cuando ya desarrollamos la idea
y empezamos a ver que inspiramos y
motivamos a gente de todo el mundo y
empezamos a ver que algo realmente era
posible y la gente
creía en nosotros y creía que también
iba a ser posible fuimos alumnos
universidades
y personas de todo el mundo que nos
contactaron por correo y nos dijeron oye
yo también quiero lanzar un satélite voy
a hacer lo mismo que puedes pasar los
planos este es el momento en el cual yo
ya lo conseguiré un éxito ya dije hemos
hecho nuestro trabajo hemos inspirado y
hemos motivado a personas
en este ámbito para poder hacer las
mismas cosas
y esto que veis aquí estas líneas
horizontales son las primeras las
primeras señales de su actividad es
desde el satélite son paquetes de
información recibidos en el área por una
persona al otro lado del mundo que
contiene la temperatura el estado de la
electrónica que contiene cómo se está
comportando con la radiación de nuestro
satélite y esto fue la primera señal la
representación del éxito de la misión ya
funcionando y con esto ya estamos
contentos de que el satélite funcionaba
de hecho lleva ya 50 días en órbita pero
nosotros ya sabíamos que había una
posibilidad de fracaso y sabíamos que
podía fracasar la misión ya teníamos el
evento desde antes el primer éxito
principal al cual queríamos aspirar y si
falla la misión lo habríamos hecho de
nuevo porque en la vida como ejemplo un
examen o una oposición vamos a poder
repetirlo vamos a poder tener segundas
oportunidades sin las constantes son el
esfuerzo y la pasión que tenemos por
algo realmente la variable es sólo el
tiempo como está diciendo antes
o cinco años y de verdad creemos en algo
y queremos obtenerlo lo único que
debemos hacer es seguir trabajando en
ello hasta que lo podamos conseguir y
bueno nos salió todo perfectamente el
satélite tuvo un fallo y no se abrieron
las antenas por lo que ahora mismo está
funcionando con un rendimiento reducido
sin embargo hemos podido analizar cómo
ha funcionado lo que es crear la red del
internet de las cosas con este satélite
y cómo se está comportando actualmente
el satélite en unos meses volverán a
entrar en fosas saturó en la atmósfera
pero por un momento pasa por encima
vuestras cabezas todos los días el sueño
cumplido de un joven
[Música]
[Aplausos]